and on the mound it's dallas kykel the
lefty this guy is an all-star a gold
glove winner two-time american league
all-star 2015 and 17. and the 2-1 pitch
a little pop-up on the right side of the
infield it's jose abreu to squeeze that
one in a 1-2-3 top of the first inning
dakota hudson a big right-hander last
year he was absolutely brilliant 16 wins
for a rookie era of 335 first base it's
a ground ball but it's a base hit and ta
is on rarely do you see him go two games
without a hit and he opens game three of
the series with a single
swing and a miss and he struck him out
with the breaking ball first strikeout
for dakota hudson two on two out and
eloy jimenez coming up
rip pass third into left field a base
hit and tim is coming on home and eloy
jimenez continues to torch the baseball
times last year
in the air out to center dillon carlson
going back with room and makes the catch
and we're going to the second inning one
nothing chicago three ground ball outs
out of five so far for dallas kykel as
dylan carlson will take a look at kykel
for the first time here's the pitch and
carlson strokes that one into left field
to base it that was just off the inside
corner he gets the first cardinal hit of
the day extending the inning to andrew
kisner now the 1-2 pitch on the ground
toward third charging in his montana
glove grab and throw he's going to be in
time and the inning has come to an end
john
who was plucked by the cardinals out of
independent ball and he makes his major
league debut right now
off the mound that eats mendic alive and
danny still
handles it while getting handcuffed that
is a really difficult play you can't
really know what kind of bounce you're
going to get off the mount can you well
you can't no you you really can't
anticipate it because sometimes it
flattens out sometimes it takes a high
hop and the pitch from kykel bounced
back up toward the middle backhand there
by mendic quick throw the first gonna be
in time danny mendick a couple of very
nice plays here in this third inning
that's our 15th outfit first with one
out for tyler o'neill it's one nothing
white sox in the fourth and o'neal skies
that in the air to right field coming in
now is no mar mazzara angling toward the
line now camping under it to make the
catch sculpture we'll head back to first
now with two away in the fourth inning
goldschmidt off first two outs fourth
inning one nothing white sox and the
pitch swing and a miss strike three got
him surgical performance once again by a
doctor dallas kykel he'll walk off the
bounce jose abreu brayu drew the walk
with two outs to keep the inning going
and eloy jimenez came through with the
rbi single
2-2 pitch he swings at that one and
misses boy did he chase hudson got him
to chase way out of the zone and picks
up strikeout number two off the plate is
where kisner sets up and that's where
the pitch goes the swing of the miss he
strikes out encarnacion he got him to
chase so two strikeouts in the inning
three overall for dakota roell ramirez
the radio texas in a major league debut
swing and a miss a slider down an end
strikes out luis robert that's a nice
start to the big league career for rauel
ramirez way to go royale two one two out
from oncotta
johan drills it way back right field
lookout goose it's a three run shot and
he took it out way back 417 and just
like that a little daylight between the
sox and the cardinal and there's a high
fly ball to deep right field the white
sox have gone back to back yes money
grand all over the bullpen and right his
first white sox home run and it's now
five nothing white sox here in the fifth
oh boy that one a line drive to left
field and bring him home
a three homer inning and it's six
nothing white sox and he absolutely
hammered it
in the air left field eloy jimenez to
the line and gone again
four in a row
and a seven nothing lead ties a major
league record it's the tenth time it's
ever happened five is not happening the
bases are loaded they're loaded for matt
carpenter
carpenter
base headed to right
one run is in
here comes another and the cardinals get
on the board matt carpenter comes
through with the bases loaded yet again
so five and two thirds for dallas kykel
he leaves with the lead
and there's a smash in the center racing
in now luis robert he slows up he makes
the catch and the inning has come to an
end so the one out base hit by dexter
fowler
oh he cut him down to his knees jimmy
cordero strikes out nagowski two on
payoff pitch
cold strike three
it's all over in the seventh inning and
the cardinals strand a pair he's up for
the eighth time and you could hardly be
any better than he's been
that's one out good fast ball for a
strike
two up two down a sweeping breaking ball
this one popped up
anderson comes in
monkatta takes it and the sox wins 7-2